All right, I haven't done like a comprehensive
where we are in the pandemic type update for
some time, but it is time to do it.
A lot of things have changed and there is
much to discuss.
So to begin with, we're starting to see some
really significant improvements taking place.
Vaccines are being rolled out more significantly.
I know about the variants.
I know about the so-called mutant strains.
And I will talk about them.
I'm not ignoring them.
I'm aware of them.
I have the latest information as to how they
will affect the vaccination program if this
or if that.
So I'm not ignoring that.
Just give me five minutes to get to it.
I know that it's what a lot of folks have
been focused in on, but let's dove right in.
So first of all, cases, just the top line
case number.
Back in December, I predicted cases would
peak permanently around January 10th, the
15th.
Now, how did I do this?
Am I an epidemiologist?
No.
Am I a public health expert?
Was I special in predicting this?
No.
Do I want a pat on the back?
Yes, but not for this.
A combination of experts were pointing out
that given the winter peak and vaccines being
rolled out and the holiday effect, we were
likely to see a peak sometime around the middle
of January.
And case in point case, that's upon the peak
for the seven day case.
Average came on January 11th when the United
States hit an average of two hundred and fifty
five thousand cases per day.
Since then, the number of cases has dropped
by more than 40 percent to a seven day case,
average of one hundred and forty seven thousand
cases.
So the bad news is one hundred and forty seven
thousand new cases a day is insane.
It's tragic.
It's a disaster being down close to 50 percent
in new cases per day in just a three week
period.
That is absolutely fantastic.
And I expect that by the end of the week we
will be down that full 50 percent.
Now, cases is one thing, but what about deaths?
We also had reason to believe that the death
peak would come three or four weeks after
the case peak.
Why did we have reason to believe that?
Well, we know from the last year of this pandemic
that deaths lag cases by three to four weeks
and indeed the seven day rolling average of
deaths plateaued over the last seven to 10
days and hopefully, hopefully will be on its
way down soon.
I had thought yesterday or today would be
the peak.
It turns out we've had sort of a plateau.
Let's hope that those death numbers go down
from here still.
And I want to be clear that even as we see
things improve, we don't want to forget that
thousands of people have been dying in the
United States every day, 4000 down to three
thousand is still insane.
It's still a 9/11 every single day.
And there is a very long way to go.
But the good news is that the numbers are
doing what we thought they would in early
December based on a lot of different factors,
including vaccination.
Let's now talk about that.
Officially, the U.S. has seen about 27 million
coronavirus cases and the U.S. has now administered,
not distributed, administered 33 million vaccine
doses into the arms of folks.
So we now have officially more doses than
a number of cases.
That's a nice milestone.
Now, if you remember my interview with Dr.
Eric Topol a couple of weeks ago, our best
guess right now is that the real number of
cases when you consider that many people never
get tested because they're asymptomatic or
they have mild symptoms and just never going
get a test, the real number of cases is believed
to be somewhere between two and three times
the official number.
But still, it's a nice thing to be able to
say.
We've now given doses.
We've given significantly more doses than
the number of total cases as of right now.
As of this morning, eight percent of the US
population has received at least one dose,
and about two percent of the US population
has received both doses.
Remember, with the Pfizer vaccine, you have
twenty one days between dose one and two.
With the Moderna vaccine, you have twenty
eight days between dose one and two.
You are not considered to be at maximum immunity
potential.
And remember, not everybody develops immunity,
but close to 95 percent do.
You're not considered to have completed the
full course of vaccination and antibody generation
until seven to 14 days after your second dose?
What we know is that these vaccines are working
really well.
Infections and hospitalizations are down among
those first vaccinated.
This includes health care workers and nursing.
Home residents, the two vaccines in play are
Pfizer and Moderna, and although the rollout
was a little bit slower than we would have
hoped, they are accelerating dramatically.
Pfizer going to bring in additional manufacturers.
A lot is happening there.
We also have a third vaccine and more.
But most imminently we have the Johnson and
Johnson vaccine imminently to be submitted
for approval.
And within a couple of weeks after that, hopefully
emergency use authorization.
That's a one shot vaccine.
Now, let's talk about the mutant's, the variants.
We have the UK variant, the Brazilian variant
and the South African variant.
The concern being vaccines are or might be
less effective against those variants.
Some people already going as far as to say
they won't work.
The vaccination program is in vain.
We're vaccinating against the strain that
is not even the strain.
OK, let's stop.
Let's sort of break it down a little bit into
its component parts, because much of what
we are being told so far is not true.
First of all, the rate at which these I don't
want to call them primary.
Yeah, I guess we could call them primary variants
or significant variants are mutating is exactly
as expected for this type of virus.
Nothing is happening that was not predictable
in terms of these types of viruses and mutation.
That's number one.
Number two, the as close as we can currently
get to a reality based assessment of the effectiveness
of vaccines on the variance is as follows.
The two vaccines currently in use, Fizer and
Moderna, in the United States appear to be
essentially as effective against the UK variant
and the Brazilian variant as they are against
the sort of main strain as we might know it.
It is true that the antibodies generated by
these vaccines appear to be less effective
against the South African variant.
That doesn't mean that they don't still generate
enough antibodies to be immune for most people
against the South African variant.
And what I mean by that is as follows.
When you vaccinate people, they generate antibodies
on a curve.
And, you know, we talk about it's 95 percent
effective.
What we mean by that is five percent of people
who get the vaccine don't generate enough
antibodies for immunity.
Now, you might still generate enough to avoid
a hospitalization or a death, but five percent
don't generate enough antibodies for immunity
to the primary strain.
But you have a curve, so you might have just
sign fake numbers to it.
95 percent of people generate at least a 100
level of antibodies, 90 percent generate at
least 200 level of antibodies, 80 percent
or at the thousand level, so on and so forth.
While it appears to be true that the antibodies
generated are less effective against the South
African variant, it may still be effective
enough for most people to be immune.
Imagine that the antibodies generated are
a thousand level and only 100 of them are
effective against the South African variant.
Well, if the threshold to be immune is only
ninety five, then you're still OK and I hope
I'm being clear about that.
So we still are gathering information about
this.
The idea that the vaccines don't work against
the variance so far is not based in fact,
or science.
It's not yet been demonstrated.
And importantly, this is a race against the
variants.
The variants are a reason to vaccinate as
quickly as possible, not to delay vaccination.
Viruses mutate by spreading.
The more people that vaccinate more quickly,
we slow the spread of the variants and prevent
more people from getting that variant, which
may be a less controlled by the vaccines.
We currently have Moderna and Fizer both working
on a sort of modified booster in case it is
necessary for some period down the road.
Could be eight or 12 months from now or maybe
even longer now.
As I said on the bonus show, I was on a wait
list for leftover doses.
A lot of of of hospitals and vaccination facilities
are having issues where because there's multiple
doses in a vial, you might get to the end
of the day and have leftover doses.
And most hospitals have some kind of on call
list.
I have a friend who works at a hospital.
I said, put me on the list.
I will give me 30 minutes notice and I will
show up.
We you know, she doesn't want any doses going
to waste, and neither do I. I was able over
the weekend to get the first dose of the Moderna
vaccine.
I had more arm pain being a lefty.
I got it in my right arm, more arm pain than
for any vaccine I've had in my life.
I had a fever and flu like symptoms for about
twenty four thirty hours.
I spent Saturday in bed, I am now feeling
fine and I'm ready and waiting for my second
dose in a few weeks.
Now, one last thing I want to talk about.
There are more and more articles being written
expressing concern that these vaccines are
being undersold and they're being undersold.
When you hear cautious public health experts
say things like even after vaccinated, you
still should social distance and wear masks
and avoid indoor crowds and all of this different
stuff.
And I think it's important to understand that
until we reach a level approaching herd immunity,
we all still need to continue taking a number
of the precautions that many of us have been
taking.
But we don't want to undersell the importance
of the vaccine because then you're going to
see a lot of people say what they are saying
now, which is even if I get the vaccine, nothing
changes.
Well, then I'm just not going to get the vaccine.
The truth is that these vaccines, particularly
Pfizer and Moderna, are almost 100 percent
effective at preventing death or even serious
covid.
That is a huge game changer.
While it has not yet been confirmed that the
vaccinated individuals spread the disease
to a significantly lesser degree, that's what
would be expected.
And that's usually how vaccines work.
So I am a little worried about the degree
to which the vaccines are undersold.
As I said on the bonus show, and as I've spoken
about with, you know, public health officials
and epidemiologists who are speaking not for
the media, but just kind of between people
in six weeks, in eight weeks, a group of four
or six vaccinated people who work from home
are able to be together with extremely low
risk.
It is not zero.
Nothing is ever zero.
But these vaccines are game changers and we
want to make sure we are not underselling
them and we continue vaccinating as quickly
as possible.
I get people are being cautious, but if we
start telling people, even with vaccination,
you still have to social distance and wear
masks.
And definitely a lot of people will say, well,
I'm going to opt out and we don't want that.
Send me your thoughts.
I am on Twitter at David Pakman.
This is good news.
Notice I didn't mention Trump or Biden in
this entire segment.
This is an analysis of the data and the science
of what is going on.
This is not a political statement, a political
segment of any kind.
Let me know your thoughts.